Oh Oh spank me once shame on you
spank me twice and now we're talking
Clinton and Trump all right it again the
apple doesn't fall far from the PC
I'm struggling after kato kaelin and now
here's your host who's tips are so
frosted you think they were flakes
brats far back
all right thank you kato kaelin all
right welcome to @midnight the show that
will go down on you in a fiat aha now
let's see what's going on in the chat
room chat room
well Clinton and Trump are at it again
yeah
Donald second marriage Trump is saying
the affair the president bill ruined
marriage Clinton had with Monica
Lewinsky would pale in comparison to the
multiple affairs he would have if he
were president there is the tangerine
dream vote told CNBC that he'd be even
sleazy or take a look can you imagine
how controversial a baby there's about
him with the women
how about me with the women Hillary
Clinton herself a woman had this
response my mama always told me the
White House is like a box of chocolates
it's pretty on the outside but inside
there's lots of nuts they got very
excited about that
she can be President someday maybe after
like a black guy personal animus aside
politicians and corporate billionaires
go together like cigars and noble
offices
I'm sure the trumps and Clinton's run
into each other socially all the time so
comedians what's a toast Hillary Clinton
might make to Donald Trump emo Philips
roses are red violets are blue you are
so so so lucky nothing rhymes with
orange Margaret Cho Zhu Donald Trump the
nicest least racist man I've ever met
yes excellent no way Donald Trump here's
to your daughter now she's pretty hot
but just a reminder just because she's
18 is still illegal your daughter all
right